we might already know what the one piece
is and where it is hidden because I
found the best theories about the big
treasure that Luffy's trying to find in
order to become pirate king starting off
with a theory that has actually already
been confirmed now in case you don't
know the only person that has ever
discovered the one piece so far was the
former pirate king Goldie Roger on an
island that is almost impossible to
reach and that most people don't even
know exists but if Roger discovered the
one piece first who put it there in the
first place well there were tons of
theories about this until Ichiro Oda the
author of One Piece confirmed that the
legendary one piece treasure was created
by a mysterious character called Joy boy
Jova was a person who lived 800 years
ago who is still super mysterious but
hugely important to the world of one
piece and in order to find joybo's
treasure which is the one piece Roger
had to read these ancient nearly
indecipherable artifacts called
pornographs if one person can find all
four more of the Red Road pornoglyphs
the road to the final treasure will be
unlocked and after Raja finally found
joyboy's treasure he laughed
uncontrollably and the island that held
the treasure became known as love tale
so what is the one piece well this next
Theory suggests that the one piece is
actually the devil fruit tree now you
probably know that the main power system
in one piece are the devil fruits
magical fruits that when eaten give a
person unbelievable Powers however we
still don't know where these devil
fruits come from how are they made why
is it that a person who eats one is
cursed to never be able to swim again
well someone who found such a treasure
and had access to tons and tons of super
rare devil fruits could form a supremely
powerful Army and so if an evil pirate
such as Luffy's main rival Blackbeard
where to find the tree that grew every
devil fruit his crew would become nearly
Unstoppable as he spread chaos and War
throughout the world the idea of fruit
tree also is connected to the atom tree
and Eve tree two giant trees speculated
to exist in the one piece world that are
heavily connected to Christian mythology
and the devil fruit creation the fruit
of the devil the forbidden fruit we
still have so many questions about devil
fruits so maybe we'll finally get an
answer at the end of the series maybe
love tale contains a giant tree that
grows these devil fruits after all the
devil fruits might not just be an
awesome power system they might be tied
into all the complex history of the
whole One Piece world now that would be
absolutely crazy but a theory that might
be a little bit less crazy is that the
one piece is nothing now that this
sounds super anti-climactic but hear me
out some fans think that when Luffy
finally reaches love tail he'll open a
treasure chest to reveal nothing at all
I mean if this were true fans the world
over with this scent upon the internet
overflowing with pure rage including me
however people who predict that the one
piece might be nothing at all have some
solid let evidence to support their
Theory one piece of evidence is that all
the way back in the East blue Saga on
the island of rare animals the early
members of the crew met a character
named gaimon and while almost every
other part of the East blue Saga serves
to set up the larger story plot the
gaimon arc which is really just a single
chapter feels a little bit out of place
everywhere else we gain a crewmate or
meet an antagonist who still plays a
role in the story however gaimon's
chapter just seems like a completely
random side quest in case you need a
refresher gaimon is this man with a
large bushy green afro who sought a
treasure at the top of a high cliff
however after falling during his climb
to the top he landed and became
permanently lodged inside his treasure
chest and then after waiting for 20
years Luffy investigates the treasure at
the top of the cliff only to find out
that there are five empty treasure
chests now given that game on and Luffy
have a lengthy conversation in the
chapter about the one piece treasure as
a whole could it is be actual
foreshadowing for the end of the series
as a whole as well did Ichiro order hide
the answer to the one piece in plain
sight all the way back in chapter 22.
after all in the end gaimon's real
treasure wasn't gold it was his hope it
was his dream in the same way the
pirates of the one piece world have set
to the sea in pursuit of their dreams a
life of adventure and making new friends
is a worthy Endeavor regardless of any
tangible outcome in the end and gaimon
despite not becoming rich became the
guardian and friend of the rare animals
on this island but if we assume that
there are clues for the one piece at the
beginning of the story then something
that seems even more likely given the
huge reveals oda's been dropping lately
is that the one piece is the ancient
Kingdom itself on the other side of
things the one piece treasure may be the
remains of the ancient Kingdom now we
still don't know a lot about the ancient
Kingdom we don't even know its real name
but what we do know is that the ancient
kingdom was an advanced civilization
nation that existed over 800 years ago
during the time that today is called the
void Century since there's so little
known about it in fact the organization
that controls the one piece world today
known as the world government originated
as 20 different nations that came
together to overthrow this ancient
Kingdom after this kingdom was destroyed
the world government then erased all the
history of its existence from the books
they completely destroyed all traces of
an entire Century however if the one
piece ends up being the remains of this
ancient Kingdom the island of Love tale
then the whole history will be Finally
Revealed the characters will learn all
there is to know about the ancient
Kingdom Joy boy and the void century and
it will finally be revealed how the
world governments took power in the
first place and what their true
Ambitions are this of course would be a
perfect setup for a final battle against
the world government to change the world
and while that does seem like an awesome
final battle maybe the one piece is
actually something that more lines ends
up with the themes of the story such as
the one piece is the friends we made
along the way the idea that the one
piece is the adventure itself or all the
friends that Luffy made along the way is
another really popular surprisingly big
Theory now this one is of course very
similar to the one we talked about
earlier that the one piece is nothing at
all and while it would be disappointing
this Theory also has some valid evidence
as well the biggest evidence for this
Theory comes from an arc called the Saba
ODI archipelago arc when Silvis Rayleigh
the former first Maid of the pirate king
Goldie Roger straight up offered to
spoil the end of the story Rayleigh who
would later on become Luffy's Mentor
told the crew that he could tell them
all the secrets of the one piece if they
wanted to hear it and in fact Usopp was
all too ready to hear all the truth of
the great treasure but Luffy quickly
shut him up because to Luffy Finding the
Treasure had no worth at all if he had
to take a shortcut to him the thrill of
Adventure the journey itself is just as
worthy as any physical treasure that he
could ever obtain and after all no
matter what the one piece actually turns
out to be in the end there will always
be some fans who will probably be
disappointed in the end anyways and so
whatever lies at the end of the grand
line probably doesn't erase how much joy
we've all had as fans in getting to know
these characters and following their
story however there is some good news
for fans who would be majorly
disappointed if the one piece turned out
to be nothing at all or Adventure or
friendship because each hero Oda has
actually gone on record stating that the
one piece is in Parts at least an actual
physical thing fans actually asked him
directly if the one piece would turn out
to be the friends we made along the way
and he explicitly said no and on that
note instead of becoming pirate king by
the way my personal journey to reach 1
million subscribers this year seems
almost impossible to do as well and it
is only doable with your help so if you
enjoyed this and want to see more of
this type of content and want to be part
of this crazy Journey this year all you
have to do is subscribe but if it's not
the friends we made along the way then
maybe the one piece is one piece as in
the one piece is the actual story dead
we're reading right now okay now this
one gets a little bit meta in fact my
brain hurts a little just thinking about
it but at the same time it is one of the
coolest theories out there let me
explain now we don't necessarily mean
that Roger was just sitting on love tail
reading manga volumes but maybe the Epic
tale that is the one piece story is
written on the unbreakable pornoglyphs
that keep the historical record of the
ancient Kingdom after all it seems like
a tale or story that makes Roger laugh
Roger actually comments on the treasure
saying that he wishes that he could have
lived in joyboy's times and that he was
way too early getting to left tail for
some mysterious reason now there's
actually a big Prophecy in the story
that says that Joy boy will return and
all hints point to Luffy being The
Reincarnation of Joy boy whatever that
actually means as you know one piece is
an exciting and hilarious manga so it
would definitely make Roger Laugh In
addition the narrator often sounds like
they're telling the story from some
future point so perhaps someone will
write the story or add to the story
that's already there and leave it on
love Tale the one piece treasure is
likely something that can unite the
whole world and nothing can bring people
together like a great story so maybe the
story of Luffy's Adventures either
through prophecy or through some weird
time travel Shenanigans is the one piece
treasure itself but before we get into
that it's finally winter time and even
though I love nothing more than taking a
nice walk in the snow it is also Prime
season for dropping your phone with your
freezing fingers I dropped mine
basically all the time but you also
don't want to use low quality or ugly
phone cases so that's where today's
sponsor comes in Rhino Shield what I
love about Den is that they created
these super protective cases for both
Android and iPhone that not only keep my
phone safe no matter how I drop it but
also have a ton of awesome designs and
Endless customizability Options just
recently for example they launched their
brand new anime collections including
Naruto Dragon Ball and Attack on Titan
and my personal favorite this kilo one
that I've actually been using for quite
a while now they even come with a
lifetime replacement warranty and so you
can get yours by clicking the link in
the description below and using my code
Ohara for 20 off for the first week and
speaking of weird time travel stuff the
one piece could also be time travel now
we already know that a character named
Toki ate the time time fruit this allows
her to jump forward in time but not
backwards but what if the one piece is
something that can travel backwards in
time now this is a very crazy idea but
what if Luffy isn't a Reincarnation of
Joy boy at all what if he time travels
back to the void century and he's
actually the original Joy boy as well
after all with the introduction of Toki
and her devil fruit ability time travel
is a real power in the story now and so
by going back and changing history Luffy
could prevent all the suffering the
world government has caused throughout
the centuries instead of just making
things better for people in the present
that would also perfectly explain why
Roger laughed at his story why he wished
that he could have met joyboy and why he
said that he was too early that's
because Luffy wasn't born yet but if
that theory is a little bit too crazy
for you how about that the one piece is
just a bunch of treasure because now we
come to what most pirates in the one
piece World actually think that the one
piece is a bunch of treasure gold jewels
riches and valuables you know basically
just a stereotypical pirate horde and
you can't blame them for thinking this I
mean Roger had gold in his name his ship
the Oro Jackson uses the Spanish world
for for gold as well Auto however what
the leagues of pirates who set out to
find this treasure fail to recognize is
that Roger isn't your typical Pirates
his treasure is almost guaranteed to not
just be monetary especially now that
we've seen Roger's reaction to love tale
and received many hints about the void
Century Joy boy and the ancient Kingdom
so much more likely is that Roger's
treasure is something related to the
great Mysteries of the one piece world
and so as disappointed as money-loving
Nami will surely be if she doesn't find
Wealth Beyond her imaginations the fan
base certainly won't be if it's
something a lot deeper than just money
and as hyped as Oda gets about this
final reveal even stating that the
series might come to an end once it's
revealed it just makes us more excited
to reach the finale for years the
fanbase assumed that finding the one
piece would then set off the final war
but the author's recent comments would
suggest that finding the one piece
actually will Mark the end of the series
in in stats so whatever it really is Oda
must imagine it will be quite the payoff
to the story could it for example be
that the one piece is on the Moon I mean
now we're getting into some Wilder
theories but the thing is this is Oda
we're talking about whatever the one
piece is going to be it is going to be
wild so even though these ideas might
seem a little bit out there at first
they're probably a lot more likely than
the theories we've discussed so far
starting with the idea that the one
piece is on the moon now I guess it is
more about where the one piece is than
what the one piece is but hear me out
for a second because you might not be
aware of it but there is something going
on with the moon in one piece the
members of The Mink Race For example
have the powerful sulong transformation
that fully depends on the full moon on
the island of O'Hara there was a
Celestial model with seven moons of the
one piece Planet the sun god Nika is
pictured jumping in front of the moon
lunarians like King are named after it
given the Luna in their name and most of
all we've seen from NL one of Luffy's
former enemies from skypeia that he
actually went to the moon in a cover
story and in nl's cover story it shows
that there are the remains of an ancient
civilization on the moon as well as
space pirates and an army of robots
clearly the moon is going to play a
major role in the story at some point so
could it be that the reason love tale is
so elusive is because it's been in outer
space the entire time on the moon enel
found ruins that seemed to depict the
winged races of the one piece world as
well as the ancient weapons so if the
strawheads went to the moon they could
learn the full truth of the ancient
Kingdom and the void Century from the
remnants of the lunar civilization and
that truth in itself could very well be
the one piece however there are some
other even more crazy locations where
the one piece could be located like the
idea that the one piece is actually
inside a giant whale so maybe one of the
reasons it's so hard for pirates to find
the one piece is because it doesn't stay
in one place this theory states that the
treasure is actually hidden inside the
belly of a giant whale as mentioned
earlier when the crew first entered the
grand line the most dangerous sea in one
piece their ship was swallowed by the
whale laboon now on the inside they
weren't digested thankfully instead they
found themselves in a very pleasant
environment as the Rogers Dr crocus had
taken up living inside Lagoon so that he
could more easily treat Lagoon's medical
problems and so what if the beginning of
the straw Hat's crew journey in the
grand line is a mirrored image of its
ending what if once again they have to
go into the belly of the whale in order
to find the one-piece treasure too one
big piece of evidence for this is that
whenever whales appear in the story The
One Piece is mentioned as well but it's
not the only place where the one piece
could be hiding another other idea is
that one piece is beneath Anna's Lobby
because during the endless Lobby Arc the
straw hats Take On The World Government
at their main judicial Center and islami
is a very peculiar Island even for 1p
standards it is always daytime there and
despite being located in the middle of
the ocean there is a massive hole in the
middle of the sea that Anna's Lobby is
built above what is at the bottom of
this hole where does it go well
according to this Theory it might just
be the one piece itself I mean after all
what better way for the government to
prevent people from Finding the Treasure
than building one of their main bases of
operation right on top of it after all
only the straw hats are insane enough to
launch an all-out assault against the
government Island and when you look at
the island itself it has these strange
ancient looking ruins on it but now
let's get back to what the one piece
actually is like the next one that one
piece is being says sake now I've
already talked about this two or three
years ago and it's a a theory that was
also popularized by another YouTuber
Arthur recently and it utilizes the fact
that the lyrics to being sake seem to
hold a lot of Clues as to the truth of
the one piece being sake is a popular
song among pirates that broke the ship's
musician sings when he's first recruited
to the crew the being saki song hints at
the drums of Liberation the coming of
the Dawn wano even loved Hill itself the
funny traveling tale both ideas that
keep reoccurring throughout the story so
this song also seems to be hinting at
joyboy's return as well and this Theory
also makes a guess at what Luffy's and
Roger's real secret dream is because on
wano it's revealed through Odin's
journal and Aces conversations with
Yamato that both Pirates share a secret
dream that for now is hidden from the
audience and so a big guess for this
dream is that Luffy and Roger's dream
was to throw a party where everyone in
the world is invited after all after
every single art Luffy loves to
celebrate with a huge party he thinks
that everyone should be able to eat and
drink as much as they want and live in
happiness and so Luffy's dream to become
a pirate in the first place was inspired
by shanks's partying at the aptly named
parties bar back in fuchsia Village
which would make this reveal
foreshadowed in a way from chapter one
basically and what do you need to throw
a party for the entire world well you do
need a whole lot of sake specifically
Bing sasake would be a jug of sake big
enough that all the world could party
together coming together as one piece
and when we think of how important the
exchanging of sake cups between asaba
and Luffy is this giant party would be
like Luffy or Joy boy exchanging sake
cups and becoming like family with
everyone across the world's ocean and
speaking of joining the world's oceans
the one piece could also be destroying
the red line now this insanely popular
Theory says that the one piece isn't an
object it's an action specific perfectly
the one piece refers to joining the
world's oceans together into one piece
by destroying the red line and Grand
line itself you probably know that
currently the people of the world are
separated from each other and the only
way for them to travel anywhere is to
cross dangerous oceans and so the four
big oceans of the one piece world the
north south east and west blue are all
separated by the x that is the grand
line and then the red line which makes
it basically impossible for most people
to travel to any other region and so not
only would merging the Seas together
make the oceans into one piece but it
would bring the world's people together
as well what's the evidence for this
idea well think back to the very first
chapter after the straw hats crew
entered the grand line when they met the
way Lagoon what was he doing other than
eating their ship well laboon was
repeatedly bashing his head against the
red line leaving it covered in scars in
an effort to reunite with his long-lost
crewmates who we later found out to be
the ship skeleton musician Brooke then
we have sanji's dream which is to find
the old blue which contains every fish
imaginable of all four oceans and our
next clue comes from Fishman Island
which is exactly one half of the grand
line away from reverse Mountain on
Fishman Island an accomplished fortune
teller Madame Charlie predicts that
Luffy will destroy Fishman Island which
again is located directly under the red
line now this prediction didn't come
true during the arc but she's never
missed a prediction quite yet so Luffy
likely will cause the destruction of
Fishman Islands before the end of the
series and it just so happens that the
red line with the world government's
capital of marijua are situated directly
across this island so if Luffy were to
destroy marijua and the entire Red Line
it would collapse upon fishment Island
destroying it however by making use of
the giant ship the Noah the Fishman
might be able to finally make their home
on the surface of the world instead of
being forced to live beneath the ocean
destroying the red line would also help
many of the straw hats fulfill their
ultimate dreams if the Seas were all
combined it would form the all-blue for
Sanji Brooke would be able to reunite
with laboon Frankie could freely Voyage
around the world and Nami could reach
any sea to draw a map of the entire
world and you can really dig down deep
here this theory in particular has a ton
of crazy evidence speaking for it it's a
crazy story that involves oars Greek
mythology and the true history of the
one piece world so I really recommend
that you check out that video right here
thank you so much for watching